Nihad palin turkin has barely set foot
in his daughter's room since she was
murdered four months ago
Helen's desk bed and dressing table are
all still there she was preparing to go
to college diploma solo I was looking
forward to framing her University
diploma and putting it up on the wall
but that will never happen now last
October
17-year old Helen was murdered on her
way home in Istanbul the culprit a male
acquaintance who shot and killed her
shortly after she had turned down his
advances incidents like these are
becoming all too common in Turkey
Helen's father has called for stricter
gun laws I want to see at least the many
illegal arms confiscated that would save
many lives because many of these
firearms are owned by uneducated people
who have a sick mentality Neha doesn't
need long to find the spot where his
daughter was killed it looks like a war
zone the culprit fired repeatedly on his
daughter with a semi-automatic rifle he
was later apprehended the man who
illegally sold him a gun however was
quickly released I or anyone else could
end up being shot soon too
this has to stop I don't want others
having to live through what I've endured
I lost my child enough there are now
fatal shootings on the streets of Turkey
every day heaven's former school friends
were shocked by her death but they know
how easy it is to buy a gun these days
it's simple you order a firearm online
and it's delivered to your doorstep
incredible really it's illegal to buy
arms online in Turkey but that does
little to allay the concerns
of girls and young women the most common
victims of male gun crime sure we're
scared every day this street corner
reminds us of the danger there are an
estimated 20 million illegal guns in
Turkey every day there are five gun
related fatalities murders accidents and
suicides private gun ownership rose by
more than 20 percent last year now an
initiative made up of citizens groups
and newspapers is speaking out it's
become easier to get a gun license all
you need is a clean police record and
medical clearance also crime and
political volatility have increased in
the past decade and penalties for
illegally owning a gun on negligable we
head over to the European side of
Istanbul after some hesitation a
firearms dealer agrees to discuss the
country's gun situation with us inside
his shot he shows us a shotgun made to
look like an assault rifle he keeps his
more serious firearms elsewhere he
doesn't think banning guns would save
lives instead he says gun ownership
should be legalized they should make it
easier to purchase a firearm legally
then the state would have control over
gun ownership and there would be fewer
fatalities culprits could be quickly
apprehended because every gun would be
registered the arms dealer regularly
showcases his arsenal on YouTube he
denies this constitutes illegal
advertising he claims he's merely
targeting gun lovers
Nihad pelant irken visits the family
grave everyday Helene who was his eldest
daughter is buried here as well she was
one of 20,000 gun crime victims in 2017
Nihat has vowed to do everything he can
to combat turkeys obsession with guns in
honor he says of his daughter